oh hello how are you
it is me Markman Arden on a special fat
man beyond live Instagram Q&A because
why the hell not it's been a minute
Kevin's been Kevin it out in the world
as one does and well as he does
I don't do it nearly as much but it's
been a while and I missed you guys
hi guys how are you yeah so hey ask away
tell me tell me what you want to know I
mean there's been out there's been a
little bit news you know in in my
particular world in that just today we
launched we announced officially the the
Battlestar Galactica that I'm doing with
Tricia Helfer that'll start on December
11th piped up into your earholes so get
it get it I hope you like it
we have been wanting to do this for a
good long while so so finally getting to
launch it into the world is is a joyous
thing so hooray for Tricia all ready for
battle star anyway so let us get to
questions let us get to questions let's
see what we got sorry the king wants to
know how excited I am for Aquaman
I am I'm not gonna say surprisingly
excited I'm excited for each and every
one of these movies that comes down the
pike I am I am sort of pleased by the
early reviews that have come out from
folks have seen it and and I am looking
forward to it I'm hoping to see it maybe
this week maybe next week who knows
so yeah fingers crossed man that'll
totally come together let's see what
else
flick crave how do I feel about
diversity altering character ie black
Superman or gay Batman how do you know
Batman isn't gay or
NNE ray he's totally into fetish gear
clearly his sex life is something that
we know very little about I would hazard
a guess I I think if it if it serves the
story and I would serves the character
and if it makes sense I mean go for it I
feel like if it if it is checking a box
and that's probably not worth doing but
yeah III have no inherent problem with
such things you know but I've also
talked at length and written far too
much I feel about why certain characters
need to remain as they were
ie white Batman but uh but yeah so I
it's a case-by-case basis but I I never
feel like tradition is a reason to keep
a thing the way it is but that is just
me Steve nerdy exploits myself I've seen
any episodes of Titans I saw the pilot
and I haven't seen any more since I
think it there's it shows some promise
but it also shows some room for growth
pilots are often the worst episodes of
any given show because you're just
figuring out right like you sure your
writers room has been in there but maybe
you wrote the pilot without the writers
room of showing up and that's just one
guy's vision and and you don't get to
realize yet what works in the show and
what does it you were just throwing
stuff up against the wall the first time
you've written it and we written it and
maybe is as good as you could make it
but you don't know yet how the actors
are gonna play together you don't know
yet the things that you'll discover over
the course of a season of writing the
show
so like there's some stuff in it that
that that I liked and then there's some
stuff in it aside all right you know
what maybe they'll figure this out maybe
maybe the pilot is going to be a little
wobbly it always is but I will check
back in when I get a chance let's see
Joey dude at 1980 wants to know about my
thoughts and the Captain Marvel trailer
I was not quite as moved by it as I was
by the first one because I just think
the the
the iconography and my first one was so
much stronger and the second trailer
seems to be a lot delivering a little
bit of story
and giving us some context for what the
movies gonna be which is cool and you
know and I dug it but uh but there there
was something a little more powerful
about that first declaration of intent
yeah
let's see and my thoughts I'm in Netflix
Marvel shows I like some of them I don't
like others what you guys I know I I
think that I I don't think we will see
those characters in those incarnations
on that Disney streaming app you know
sometimes for better sometimes for worse
you know we will get one more season of
Jessica Jones a Netflix we will get one
more season the Punisher on Netflix but
my gut is that those are the last of the
Marvel shows we'll see they're you know
when I died centered on the podcast that
you know I think that that the one the
one weakness of those shows was the tone
of similarity you know that each each of
those shows feels and you know to a
certain degree by intent I'm sure like
the same part of the same universe they
have to crossover together and they have
to make some sense together
but that tone was very dour that tones
very dark and pummeling and tongues and
I feel like after a while audiences
viewers at least I know that I I was not
feeling nearly as enthusiastic about you
know season three of some shows as that
was about season 1 of some shows that is
again because it was new at one point it
now it's not new anymore but you know
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is found a
way to mess with those tones and give
you comedies and heist movies and into
an electic space battles and and you
know just political thrillers and
paranoia and giant cosmic epic and all
of those things while still playing and
being able to pass through each other
connect with each other I think the TV
shows needed to have a little bit of
that vibe and the Netflix shows didn't
so if I had to guess the the next
version of what we'll see for
for the Marvel TV we'll have a little
bit more that fluidity of tone to me
bones 99 what I think read - I thought
it was I don't know I haven't seen it
yet I'd like to think it's great but
hopefully I'll catch up with it in the
next couple of weeks
let's see doc q4 what is the best advice
you can give someone who is taking this
shot at writing sci-fi short stories and
pilots the best advice I can give you is
to is to write and to finish and to
finishing the important part it's easy
to start stuff
everybody starts something everybody you
know opens up their laptop or powers up
their computer and and and starts
writing a story the proportion of people
who then finish that story is relatively
small so finish is huge you know figure
out the story you want to tell thinking
about the characters you want to tell
the story about character is the reason
why we connect this story right it's not
the world it's not necessarily the plot
it's the character so who are you
telling the story about and follow that
characters lead like once you get into
it once that character starts to be
alive for you you'll have a sense of
where the storm is gonna go and how to
follow it through but yeah like zero in
on your character you know don't don't
build more the world don't get lost in
building the world you could do that for
years but figure out who you're telling
the story about and who you're telling
it for and and then finish it man you
gotta finish it's all about the finish
okay let's see Korey Wilkins what biopic
what I love to write please tell me it
would be a prince one I do feel as if we
have already got him a definitive Prince
biopic it was called Purple Rain and I
do feel that that sometimes a biopic you
know I mean and I talked about Bohemian
Rhapsody which you know is is grain in
some parts glosses over stuff in other
parts feels more like a recreation than
an actual interpretation of the dude's
life
but there's also the version that is
like a a heroic poem right like a like a
like a myth
you know the stories where what's that
old quote you know if when the legend is
better than the fat sprint the legend
Purple Rain is Prince's own legend of
his own creation it's his own creation
myth are we going to get a movie that
gives us more of an insight into what
made that dude take the Purple Reign I
don't think so
you know could you make a cradle to
grave biopic just like here's princess
an eight-year-old picking up his first
guitar here's Prince you know playing
backup good whatever for this guy here's
Prince writing songs for for Ashima
Sheila you could have all of that stuff
sure but will it be a more moving
experience of prince's life than Purple
Rain
I don't think so so yeah I know that is
not one that I would like to write I had
I had pitched at one point on the
podcast that people should read a by a
biographer a biography of Alexander
Dumas the elder who was a a black
general and Napoleon's army who rose to
be you know Jesus like he was the
basically the second-in-command
Napoleon's ground forces and his is
battlefield during the do and heroics
who are astonishing until he rubbed the
wrong person or Elena ended up in jail
and then a broken man kind of returned
home to die and something resembling
obscurity except for the fact that his
son Alexander Dumas would go off and
write three musketeers and Count of
Monte Cristo which is very much based on
what he interpreted to be his father's
story um so yeah that guy well I think
would be amazing let's see Noah Parker
96 how would I feel about Marvel doing
x-men doing Avengers vs. x-men for
Avengers 5 I think it's a bit of a rush
um although I did see a quote from the
Russo brothers saying that they were
done making Avengers movies unless
Secret Wars was on the table and I'm not
gonna say that would be the best way to
introduce the x-men but it would be kind
of Awesome
I have a soft spot in my heart for Super
Wars because that was my very first
Marvel superhero comic it is it did what
it was designed to do which was every
character that's in them of the universe
is in this book and if you've never read
a mortal book before this will introduce
you to all of them and you can then say
oh it's like this and it's like the
buffets sampler platter of comic books I
like that one I'm gonna follow that guy
and that guy met lady and that team and
I'm gonna go buy the books they were in
and become a fan so if you were going to
introduce characters who hadn't been
that before but also you don't want to
retell the x-men origin stories maybe
that's a good way to do it I'm just I'm
just saying Jam Master Debbie thoughts
on Marvel fast-tracking shang-chi to
ride the coattails of crazy magicians
and replicated the success of Black
Panther I mean yeah it's and at the end
of the day this is a business right
these move they only get to make more
movies if the last movies succeed and if
the next movies can show some some
promise of doing well I think it is this
this wave of Marvel seems to be
embracing diversity in a big bad way
between like Panther and Captain Marvel
and now shang-chi realizing that there
are vastly underserved audiences who who
will turn out and turn out in force if
they see themselves on screen why
wouldn't you do that you know well
wouldn't you you know hire a woman to
code direct Captain Marvel why wouldn't
you hire an ancient screenwriter to get
after with Sharon Chi um why wouldn't
you do that stuff why wouldn't you try
and take him to the planet that Apple
which is is sitting there especially if
there's good stories to tell that lets
you do both you know that is that is the
the key to to a progressive Hollywood is
figuring out how to make money doing
what you believe to be the right thing
and telling that you believe to be
important stories and if you if you can
empower somebody like Ryan Coogler
to tell a story like blood
there which is is deeper and more
textured and more specifically African
and african-american than any other
movie really that had come before it
definitely any other move that's made
you know almost 2 billion dollars if you
can figure out how to how to crack that
formula of letting the specific become
the universal then keep doing it well
why don't you keep doing I'd I'll keep
going you know there's an audience for
it to be sure so yeah I mean it makes it
makes a ton of sense to me so yeah I am
J sorry Ian J 19 is blood if they get a
Best Picture nomination um I don't know
I don't know I mean in a field of ten I
think it might be nine or ten there's
not a lot of conversation about it right
now and they sort of Oscar blogosphere
whatever I feel like it gets a decent
amount of craft nominations it gets a
costume design I think it's a production
design it'll probably get a VFX
nomination sound effects score for sure
but the best picture is as a stretch I
think at this point but fingers crossed
I hope Ryan gets one although that's
also on the outside yeah I mean I think
that's that that's really it that's
really it let's see j-dub 5:30 spec
script versus pilot script to break in
the business as a staff writer for TV
I'm assuming the the conventional wisdom
these days is that writing is a spec
episode which is an an episode reading
currently existing TV show like if you
gotta go off and write you know a
Sabrina or if you gonna go off and write
at Riverdale or if you're gonna go off
and write you know a Star Trek Discovery
or Chicago Fire vs a pilot script which
is your own original creation the
conventional wisdom is pilot script is
the way to go because what what a what a
showrunner is looking for is
an original voice that they can then use
to help funnel into their show and
personally I would much rather write
something that I have the chance of
selling that can also be a sample than
running something they can only be a
sample there is a lot of time in a lot
of effort to only let it do one thing
you know find a way for something to be
able to be multi-purpose so yes I would
do a pilot script personally there are
people who will say that spec script is
actually more appropriate for the job
you're gonna have to do which is I don't
have a sort of a show that's not your
own and prove that you can match a voice
which is in your own butt but it's
fallen out of favor so yeah yeah yeah
yeah James Koch 1992 what I mean kept
gonna do with that man be out of the UK
I do not know I hope it is sooner rather
than later because I had a blast when we
did the London from comic-con a couple
years ago but there's nothing currently
on the boards for that everywhere mm one
will Drew Goddard daredevil live on in a
feature film I sure would love it to you
know I sure would love it if if the
Disney app would find a way to just do
like Marvel dark you know kind of what
defenders sugar being wasn't but just
wrap up characters like daredevil and
blade and publisher and just put them
all in the same show and maybe even make
an anthology
you know they've been officially ties
together but yeah I mean you can
absolutely do that
let's see Matt will post do we have
opinions on the cowboy bebop show and if
so what do you think about the Netflix
live-action adaptation underway I think
it's a fabulous idea because yeah I
think you know the enemy will always
live on you know there's there's that
old Raymond Chandler quote
well you know somebody would ask him how
do you feel about you know Hollywood you
know destroying your book and he would
always point to a shelf and say my book
is [ __ ] it's right there there will
always be the cab would be about anime
he will always live there in eternity
for you to look at but I think that a
lot of action version of that like well
how is that a bad thing and I happen to
know one of the guys who's working on it
how the air grill marks watch who is one
of the best writers I've ever met so I
have faith see boxcar Josh and Aria tell
us the idea of good guy with a gun but
when it's black guy they end up getting
shot do you see this thing making its
way into comic book movies black hair is
getting shot by police
well boxcar Josh I will direct you to a
little book that I wrote called genius
and and geney's cartel for Top Cow which
deals head-on with those things so yeah
go for it let's see protagonist radio
spike or angel spike is way more fun
but yes Mike let's go spike here are we
puppet man
boom night how is it working with your
help on the new podcast I bet there's
wine lots of wine there is a fair amount
of wine Tricia has a a pretty decent
wine cellar I also have a pretty decent
credit card so no I buy one one week she
buys wine the next week and me drink
wine and talking about Battlestar and it
is super fun I cannot wait for you guys
to hear what we've been talking about
but yeah it's it's a it's a grand old
time
thanks Boone a um Tiger Mendoza kiss
have had their own comic which other
band artist deserves the comic treatment
huh you know I feel like there could be
some amazing Janelle Monae comics um you
know given that that she is a concept
album artist and especially some of her
earlier work is all very hairy like
sci-fi cyborg retro futuristic afro
futuristic I would have
every the hell out of it you know money
coming I'll be amazing um let's see that
I did it Randy similar once inner wasn't
I doing a Battlestar Gallactica podcast
haha
yeah man we are December 11th dropping
into your ears
soon enough let's see
but dippity boom boom ba-ba-boom
protagonist radio what's a nonfiction
book you'd recommend for fiction readers
I would recommend endurance about Ernest
Shackleton's voyage to the bottom of the
world and how it went horribly awry but
still ended up being an amazing
testament of as the top science
endurance and in Tiffany in Turpan era
bike rack our is phenomenal
feels like it's fiction but totally
isn't well that's a it gets tiring it's
so dark so chair not 685 let's I be ax t
I've axed I guessed given the
opportunity to write one Marvel
character which one would would you
adapt into the MCU
I would do blade I loved Lane I think
blade is is is there's so much potential
there do not just talk about vampires
and killing them in fun and interesting
ways but to get to talk about you know
addiction and class and race
specifically biracial like the biracial
experience in America because blade is
by speciall I guess he's half-human
half-vampire does not really belong in
either world but finds a way to walk
through both
I think the metaphor there is super
super strong so yeah I'm having blade
there's a TV show another TV show to be
made out of blade which could be amazing
let's see hey Jay Reid man would you
like to see more vertical projects on DC
here s transmitter Politan perhaps
transmit would be amazing trans man is
waiting to be a fantastic TV show you
know I still believe cinnamon is way
better as a TV show than whatever B is a
movie let's see yeah I mean so much that
early vertigo stuff like I still think
there's a really good way to make a
Hellblazer show I was watch they can't
erase me the other day and and it's it's
I always forget how strong that movie is
it's a little goofy at times but and
much of that goof has to be with Shia
LaBeouf who adds a source oh no goof
ever ever at every turn but uh but yet I
think there's there's totally a way to I
mean the Justice League dark movie that
Chioma was gonna make a thousand years
ago
give me that as a TV show bring it and
watch it
let's see protagonist radio who won
Castle Rock would make the best
gunslinger I mean you got Scott glammy
it's got Lenny Bennett yeah no [ __ ] it
Scotland oh if you can shoot Scott Blunt
you Scott Glenn let's see Chris crispy
cakes
wispy cakes what film serious would you
love to rescue from development hell hmm
you know I think there's there is still
at 20,000 Leagues Under the Sea movie
that has been threatened since forever
getting to see Captain Nemo for real
would be kind of great if you haven't
seen Guillermo del Toro's list of film
scripts that he's written some 16 of
them then that are fully written and
are currently not being made any one of
those will do any one of those his hog
show [ __ ] yet I don't watch the hell out
of it
let's see meri yaad 84 what are my hopes
and aspirations for the live-action Last
Airbender series are you pushing to
write on it my hopes and aspirations are
that it is as good as the animated show
was if not better and given that it's
those two guys doing it who who were who
were vociferous about how much they
hated and Nights adaptation of it I
think it's in good hands what I love to
read on it absolutely doesn't look like
I will write on it absolutely not but I
live in hope mm let's see hello hey okay
yomo la ma 1701 a reporting for duty sir
have you watched any episodes of Doctor
Who featuring Judy Whitaker
I've seen the first two I'm woefully
behind on my television watching and I
kind of loved it
so far um she's got a great energy she
does not seem to I mean every doctor is
different I quite like the Matt Smith I
loved I loved David Tennant you know
Christopher Eccleston was just just
weird and it was my given the first time
I started watching was a heckle so I was
like all right I get it you know he's a
little Daffy and kind of odd but sure
he's an alien I get it um I I that was
not in love with the Capaldi stuff some
it was because I found him a little hard
to understand the Scottish being a
Scottish as it was just I'd a it didn't
hit my ears right but but there-there
was not the kind of I don't know indeed
there was a joy to vu that was not
present for his but I and I so far
really like enjoyed Whittaker so yeah I
am on board I'm on board
JB 308 7:00 when will you get a mark
Barnard and funkopop you want it so bad
you gotta talk to the Funko people I am
not the one holding up a a Funko pop
um so yeah give give them a shout
long-bearded pimp he'll say alright you
know you do you let's see this shiny
llama 13 how do you think creators can
deter the top tech fan bases sent it
around their work I think that the only
way to dispel darkness is to shed some
light don't be silent about it if you if
you see it beginning to fester if it's
already there don't shy away from it you
know the only the only way to make that
stuff go away is to help point out how
ludicrous and ridiculous they are so
yeah just shine a light baby let's see
Jamie cat ears white what kind of class
would a 40 plus you're a person get the
best knowledge from when actual
university is not an option it depends
on what kind of knowledge you're looking
for
it depends on what you're wanting to
utilize that knowledge for but I do
think that we are we are all of us
gifted and gifted with the access to and
cursed with the ignorance of the fact
that we have access to the greatest
storehouse of knowledge ever before
presented and accessible to human people
your phone your computer a library you
know like 20 years ago if you want to be
a screenwriter you had to go to NYU or
you UC or UCLA or one of a handful of
schools that specialized in filmmaking
today you listen to podcast today you
could you know go to seminars given for
free you know there's there was more
knowledge being handed out for almost
nothing today then there ever has been
in the history of the planet whatever
you want to know you can find out
usually for free if you gotta pay how
much is it gonna cost you you know what
what at what use is it you know that's
not true
I was about to say what uses are do go
to film school today there is years
you know it's but that uses is forming
bonds and connections with your
classmates and the access to equipment
you pretty much have a film student in
your pocket you pretty much have a
distribution network on your laptop you
can Twitter has brought people together
in ways that were previously impossible
most of the things that one used to go
to college for you can get in the real
world for almost nothing saying if the
piece of paper that since you went to
that college but the more time passes
the less that piece of paper is actually
worth as much as you pay for it given
that you could make a thing so depending
on what you want to know I bet you you
can get that information out there and
then however you want to use it that's
that is entirely up to you let's echo
thr33 if I were to fix one of Kevin's
movies which one would it be and how
would you fix it
[ __ ] you man come on to play that game
with you no no let's see
gibbehhh Soros he'd love to pitch it
Tommy Monahan show but I understand 1/8
a simple process can you guys ever
discuss your question pitch or is there
an end being in the way um you know I
think Kevin has talked about it before I
can't remember we've ever talked about
it before you know I mean the way it
happened was DC came to him and says
Hank do you want to do the question and
he said yeah I'd love to do the question
and he asked me want to do the question
I said yeah that sounds like fun you
know being Kevin opens doors the way um
in ways that they don't get open for
most people and that just is where it is
um you know but it didn't happen
ultimately because there were rights
issues at its core that you know we
couldn't untangle so it's just another
another pitch for the pile that will
never get made but the woman fun it
would have been fun
see Tiger Mendoza cold Cobra Kai is
surprisingly good any other 80s classics
you feel deserve a similar treatment um
Manimal duh you know I think there's
probably a way to do um Beauty and the
Beast again oh that was in 90s classic
hey I I would watch a writer show any
day of the week I know they tried to do
it before I don't give a [ __ ]
I would watch and I write a show
tomorrow if he told me they were making
one so yes my leg still Walsh 12 most
influential TV show of this century the
21st century um interesting
um the hope was lost lost was 2001 right
I mean that qualifies yeah I think it's
probably lost maybe Breaking Bad
maybe Battlestar Galactica but yeah I
mean yes I think those three if lost is
in there
I mean networks have been chasing lost
and trying to replicate that success for
the last 15 years yeah so one of those
three I think let's see Jacob D 87 if
given the opportunity would you like to
try your hand at directing yes I'm still
hoping to keep to my promise to make a
feature film before I'm 50 I have three
years left and suddenly I'm busy but I'm
hoping to keep to it I really am
let's see Shelton 92s Shelton 92 with
the arrival of the x-men imminent in the
MCU idea with Magneto having history of
being a Holocaust survivor well I mean
he's a mutant
mutants can be old they can be older
maybe maybe the magnetic powers have
[ __ ] the aging process hell I mean
if Captain America can still be a
survivor of a veteran of World War two
then I feel like magneto can still be a
Holocaust survivor but uh but yeah I
think I think you keep that and I think
you just figure out a way to make that
work art works am I looking forward to
the new class movie I am because despite
what I said about in that Sharmila is
the last airbender movie I still think
that guy's Got Talent and I think that
that sort of embracing his own universe
in this way is it's kind of interesting
so yeah I am uh I will I will totally
get a sweat on that
[Music]
let's see BC d'oeuvre favorite fantasy
sword & Sworcery works any property want
to get your hands on a possibility of a
crater on endeavor in the genre I grew
up my one of my foundational texts is
calling the Barbarian those were the
first books that I that I devoured the
entire series out of everyone I get my
hand on so so there is there is a
there's a soft spot in my heart for
dudes with sort of furry loincloths and
giant swords hacking their way to glory
if I could get a hold of Conan the
Barbarian I would love to write it if
there is a corner out there and TV show
that um that may ever get made I love to
write on it but I mean I don't I've
never thought about you know launching
my own sword & Sworcery thing I don't
the appetite that I have for it is more
the appetite to write that character
than it is to just play with those
tropes so probably not but but never can
tell
[Music]
it's armand damn it you want to find out
what I'm doing which I offer its roll
out there it's all out there baby
in these broke today let's see grano
Juanico Sanchez what book should Matt
Reeves adapt or choose for inspiration
for the Batman movie I mean year one you
know I think there's there's a great
story in that to be certain because you
want to see him is detective you want to
see him you know I don't necessarily
need to see him as part of the Justice
League fighting everything from outer
space I receive a fighting crime a
broken man in Gotham City so yeah that's
that would be my call let's see
ro a Gwen ro agen when will mean Kevin
hook up for any fat man beyond very soon
mid-december is what it's looking like
so yeah I hope I hope it's sooner than
that but you know schedules are what
they are and so we'll get there when we
can let's see uncle J mo quick question
whoever punched anyone in the face yes
let's see
Jake Jay Roth where are some strategies
utilize to keep motivated well while
writing a larger project tiny deadlines
um I mean deadlines are the fuel for
completion at least for me personally
you've got another deadline I will
wallow in my own filth and I will play
video games and I'll watch movies if
there is no deadline so I need to set
one for myself life tends to help offer
deadlines like you know at least for me
being a TV writer it is a freelance job
at best so you work for six months seven
months eight months and then you're not
working for a couple of months then you
hopefully get another job and that span
between them can be you know can be
short or longer
but I want to use that time between to
write something for myself so if I've
got two months off then I got to finish
something two months at eight months
I've got to finish so many months but
those deadlines are for me the key I
like to bribe myself
video games used to be that thing for me
you know I write I do recall writing a
pilot at one point one of my first ones
and using Skyrim as the reward that I
sat there on the plastic up on the shelf
and I could not play it until I was done
with the pilot
so fun ways to trick yourself into doing
something yeah basically is cutting
yourself into doing the work let's see
way to rock does the movie industry get
superhero fatigue anytime soon I'm
hoping not of he's hoping that I think
at some point we will slow down I think
I think they're there especially there
was a flurry of people buying universes
right like the valiant universe got
bought and this universe got bought in
the Miller world got bought I think we
are beginning to see not that Marvel
will slow down not that DC will slow
down per se but I think the peripheral
sort of universes are going to to to
maybe not make their way to the screen I
think that people are beginning to
realize that it is not the people in
superheroes is it people want these
superheroes and DC still has a lot work
to do to rekindle that love in the
hearts of people but um but yeah I I
hope that kind of sort of answers your
question
let's see mine is cold 95 we think that
we should get a reboot for the big
screen
I don't know I mean we saw that the NBC
live version of it which was kind of
cool you know I don't know I don't know
how much how much residual love there is
out there excuse me for either the Wiz
or the Wizard of Oz for that matter
I think you know we'd get we'd see
wicked the movie before we see another
Wiz on the big screen
let's see dB Eric 13 as 1 if you have
any question on a focus on a single
project I'm a writer and have lots of
ideas but I can't finish any of them
because anyone comes I get distracted by
that yeah no I understand the Lee sort
of pretty girl syndrome or pretty boy
syndrome of ideas
whoo that was so shiny focus focus oh
but so shiny
focus focus I think you have to it's
that's the discipline right it's getting
it done I think you do have to indulge a
little bit your brain does need to roam
sometimes you know whatever the Pomodoro
Technique is or for 45 minutes and you
take 15 minutes off and let your brain
sort of rejuvenate itself if a new idea
comes into your head jot it down like
you know write down the bare bones of it
give it give it you know an hour of
indulgence and then you put it down and
you focus on that on the thing at hand
because finishing is way more important
than having ideas that you never
finished
so yeah let's see Aquaman Crete will I
see him not yet Henry Finkel do I have a
favorite movie composer hmm I think
right now it's Michael Giacchino I think
his incredible score is phenomenal I
think he's right A to E score is
phenomenal
I think his Mission Impossible stuff is
great I think he's incredibly versatile
I am a huge fan of Ludvig goranson who
did the Black Panther soundtrack
the discipline to get those sounds just
right to mix the traditional with the
contemporary and use those kind of tunes
for characters you know I will always be
a bit of a John Williams head because
you know John Williams
um yeah sure I think you know the John
Berry's of it all
James Horner I think was fantastic I
love his alien squirrel it was glory
score yeah you know there's there's
there's for sure a bunch of within a
minute that I love so yeah everywhere W
on again she busines release some of the
South American troops during the service
I think they should release it I don't
know where it should be probably as a
video release
maybe another streaming service bud you
know we should not hide from who we were
you know just be acknowledge the fact
that it's it's awful and misguided but
do not don't attempt to erase it
let's read your smile 88 coming back to
Kansas City in time soon that is
entirely up to Kansas City we had a good
time and it was a pretty good show so
bring us back and may be ready to roll
let's see Padre Chris who do you have
director fantastic for once they're
finally in the MCU give the Bradbury
fella call
yeah he seems to know how to do team
superheroes they're also families
incredibly well let's see how do you
down
Cuba's DSU I'm a writer Kevin Spence of
director of each other that's talked
about working together all the time
you know maybe we're already a hard
[Music]
let's see talked about Blaine already
corn needs a comic yeah okay sure a corn
can have a comic I guess let's see
Hailey's Halley's Comet I'm certain that
you've been asked this before but is
there a kids book that you would love to
see how they're on the big or small
screen
um you know yeah it's funny like I I
went through a very big reading kids
books raised because you know had kids
who wanted to be read to I was an up
falling back on unstuff like dr. Seuss
talati dr. Seuss
well the wild things are always a
favorite um I think there could be
something really interesting
Ezra Keats wrote a book called snowy day
about this this black kid on the
projects who gets to play out in the
snow and that experience I think you
could you know what what doesn't key to
lives in the projects imagine the world
to be if the world could be anything
that you can make with snow I think it
could be phenomenal I'm just saying I
don't even thought about that before but
hey thanks it was a good question let's
see any news from Castle Rock Season 2's
Henry think'll I know that they are
currently busily writing it I am NOT a
part of it maybe I could be a part of
season three if and when that happens
but season two the intelligence from
inside the room is that it's going well
let's see Jamie can tears wants to know
with where's the podcast which is a hell
for them to be hosted Syfy will host it
but it will be available on Apple
podcasts and iTunes and stitcher or any
app you use to get podcasts and an RSS
feed so it'll just automatically
populate yeah no it's all good it's it's
gonna be unavoidable if it's something
you want let's see we are almost coming
to the end of our time here
if I were guiding the MCU does surely
become ironheart I mean why the hell not
right like at some point Robert Downey
Jimmy would be too expensive to play
Ironman
um at some point Tony Stark will have to
take a back seat and Sheree stole Black
Panther almost every time she was on
screen and she's a certifiable genius
and she can be Lama and [ __ ] so yeah
that seems that seems a little bit of a
no-brainer let's see
metal edit or I'm on course to writing
my first short film about a famous
character there's no way to get a good
balance you know people love and trying
to bring entirely sure what that
question is
good balance clicks my people love and
trying to bring something new to a
franchise I lost I lost the question in
the middle there let's see 7c know what
influence the studios to make a property
a movie versus TV in line there are some
stories that are inherently built for a
finite telling and an open-ended telling
something should be two hours and
something should be hundred hours you
know I think that that a character like
Sherlock Holmes you know like yeah I
mean you can make a movie you can make
two or three movies and you know they
could be good they can just be one
adventure in that guy's life or you can
make elementary or you can make Sherlock
and you can dig into that character it
is about you know movies are about sort
of spectacle and one day in a person's
life give or take and television is
about character and every day in that
person's life and being able to dig
deeper and longer and honor things that
you don't have time for in a movie um
you know I think that often Studios
choose movies because I think there's
more money in it you know I'm sure like
Ethan Hunt and Mission Impossible yeah
they've made more than a billion dollars
on all those movies and that makes sense
but you know could you do Ethan Hunt as
a TV show that's where I came from
you know every week was a different
heist a different colony different
mission you know so I think some of it
is is the character rich enough to make
it a worthwhile commitment or is this
idea more about spectacle in WoW versus
character I think anyway let's just
podcast if I had to do a long distance
road trip in which three superheroes
would you pick to join you
let's see storm because of weather would
always be nice um long shout because
we'd have the luck of the draw we've
never hit traffic and I'm not sure why
it's all x-men but uh but just in case
if you got a how about that just in case
got Logan assured just in case crack and
I bet you he knows all the best bars
let's see you there why you either can I
explain why I like Venture Brothers I
like it because it it began as like a
scooby-doo slash Jonny Quest the
pastiche you know and and and was fun
and was funny and not only did you know
it checked all the boxes that you wanted
to do there it was a good time but over
over it's it's run it is involved into
this crazy meta adventure and and you
know like that
the balls of that show to be whatever it
wants to be whenever it wants to be it
ah
it's something I appreciate so yeah it
is it is brazen in a way the most
animations brazen it is it is
manifesting for grown-ups
but it also understands the Daffy
underpinnings of something like Jonny
Quest so yeah I just love it for all
that it does
blondie blondie blah blah at the DVD
oh man that hook sure I know right
thank Japan yeah partner semi pun but a
zombies dead I mean they Sharma I I
don't think we get an ozone be show on
TV for a good long while I think you
know what what appetite there was for it
and it was a vast rabbit i p-- I think
Walking Dead has satisfied that
particular hunger you know I think that
uh didn't say if I have a show also I
forget the name of that one it's got Z
in the title um somebody will remind me
but yeah like I think that that given
the vets share was as big as it was as
huge as it was starved out every other
possible competition on the zombie front
except that sci-fi show and that its
viewership is beginning to decline I
don't think that anybody else for a good
long while attempts another zombie sure
at least one that's that's about the
survivors that way I would love to see a
miniseries in my World War Z because I
think that that's a different enough
tank because it's about that's you say
it's about the people but so much of it
is not ever showing you zombies at least
the way the book is laid out um so yeah
I think I think I think it's around
let's say bangs onre but I think that
it's uh it is going to take a good long
dirt now for a while um let's see I
think that we may have to pull the plug
right about here they have the top of my
screen is beginning to blink saying that
um you know we were running out of time
running out of time um let's see j-dub
five thirty what do I think about a
she-hulk series for Netflix I think
about a shayok series for Marvel I feel
like if you have
here's the thing there there there's
there are three kind of shows that will
always run on TV doctor shows cop shows
and lawyer shows if you gonna tell me
that you could have a lawyer show that's
also a superhero show
I mean Dana Ville was almost kind of
that but not really but if I she hug
[ __ ] yes done and um let's see
I did get into a knife fight a mistake
lost
I cut the [ __ ] out of that steak the
Hughes E is Tom Cruise still a top star
in Hollywood if not who is I do think
that star power is not measured the way
that it used to be I think that that
franchises are the new movie stars and
that a franchise can get a movie
greenlit more than a star can I think
Tom Cruise can get a certain kind of
movie Greenland namely a movie that
stars even hunter Jack Reacher Will
Smith used to be the biggest star in the
world but you know we really haven't
seen that flex in a good long while and
if it's still there
I think Michael B Jordan has about as
much heat as anybody does in Hollywood
and it helps for certain get stuff made
and he seems to worry get interesting
stuff mean Chris Hemsworth can get
sharma stuff made but nobody really
wants to see him do anything else and
that's sort of the problem with modern
Hollywood
is that Chris Hemsworth has an
incredibly versatile guy
I mean Ragnarok sort of opened eyes to
what that dude could do but but he is
not at this moment the kind of guy who
can just get any movie he wants to make
made so so yeah I'm not sure that there
was a movie star left in the world who
is what cruiser Schwarzenegger or
Stallone more even Will Smith was in the
80s 90s and 2000's let's see Denzel
Washington should be the new Whistler
and the Sun should be the new blade all
right easy
like were you thinking let's see
Dave confirm which where we're going to
teaching if so what specific aspects of
writing um not yet but yeah I think I
would maybe on an adjunct professor way
as long as I give me an awesome blazer
with the patches on the elbows but yeah
I think I think that there's there's I
like having conversations about stuff I
don't necessarily want to teach stuff
but you know being able to talk about be
able to talk about writing be able to
talk about writers maybe I want to talk
about you know the stuff that I love if
they'll pay me to do that
boom if I get the jacket with the
patches boom
let's see using one so no two pizzas or
a pizza and Chinese takeout I don't
understand how any of those are bad so
yeah let's see what do you think about
the possibility of a new black mirror
episode having a choose your own
storyline from simply e best you know I
I think it's an interesting gimmick and
I'd watch it for certain for certain for
certain but but I come to a show like
black mirror to surrender myself to that
to Charlie Brooker and his stories I
don't necessarily want to tell one of
those stories I just want him to tell me
one that I love so yeah I hope that it
doesn't catch on but I love that they're
trying it let's see can hazel what do I
think of the Lion King live-action I
think it's it's interesting I get that
it's a complete money grab on Disney's
part and that seems to be the new mode
that they're in which is take a little
thing that was a cartoon and make a
live-action and make a billion dollars
if it works for them I see it
I think jon favreau is a pretty talented
filmmaker so I think that there could be
some new wrinkles to that story that
they add to it I think the voice cast is
fantastic I kind of don't ever need to
hear the I just can't wait to be king
song again so I hope that's not there um
I do hope that Disney makes good with
the original writers of the original
movie who given that animation is not
covered by the Writers Guild of America
they do not share in residuals and they
do not need to be paid for the use of
their original work or compensated in
any way so they can paint scale they get
paid upfront and then it's what they
earn no matter how big a movie is so you
know the folks who wrote the original
Lion King will not share in any way the
success of the new one which is kind of
shitty I I think it's got a chance to be
good I have I hope that Disney will find
a way to be good to the people who did
the original work all right I think I am
going to bounce you guys it was awesome
to hang out with you guys again
hopefully we will see you at the scum
and villainy Cantina on Hollywood
Boulevard if you're in the Los Angeles
area sometime in the next well whenever
you get here if you get here we'll do a
show let us know holla back but for now
this has been a special Q&A episode of
fat man Beyond or black man Beyond as it
were I am mark Barnard the guy over
there is an acumen Smith that is my
fancy comic book rank camera make bugs
hey kids
so tune in next time the same fat time
same fat channel smart cast calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith thanks
guys
you
you